I've never given off of a painting
halfway through and sometimes in order
not to give up on it you've got to put
it away for a couple of weeks and work
on something else and then go back to it
and I've had paintings where I did that
and I've gone back to it then another
couple of weeks another couple of months
still can't get it still can't get it
but you know it's a strange thing and I
mean it's probably cliched but it's very
true it's the only thing that I can
compare it to and it is like children if
you've got a difficult child that's a
pain in the ass and you know we give up
on them you just got to keep working you
just got to keep trying to get that
right and it's the only comparison that
I make I can make I won't lose a
painting because I know I'm not going to
start a painting unless I had an idea
for I'm not going to start a painting
unless I wanted to achieve something
with this piece of work and and if it
doesn't come easy I can't leave it so so
I don't I mean sometimes the painting
will wipe the floor with me and haha be
a bundle it's halfway through but but I
won't
I won't lose a painting so known as the
answer one word
I think my mother-in-law's a very wise
woman and she said you know to make a
marker to make your mark or to try and
do something great of course the all
important thing is that you must be
talented but that's only the first 10%
and what I have seen that is so true
and people that work harder than anybody
else and achieve more than anybody else
not necessarily because they're a better
songwriter not necessarily because
they're a better painter but because
they're giving it so much more and they
refuse to fail or they refuse to settle
for less and so of course the talent has
got to be there but hard work is a
massive part of developing that gift
that talent
yeah I mean discipline for me was a
difficult thing you know I parted
company with the Virgin Bruins in 1984
to paint foe telling but I had painted
right through my years with the band and
before the band started right through my
childhood and discipline was going to be
always a problem for me because by
nature and lazy and but but I worked
hard on discipline and became
disciplined and to the point now that I
just want to be in the studio you know I
get up at about half 10 or 11 o'clock I
do my situps few press ups I go for a
fast walk have a bit of breakfast go to
the studio about 12:00 noon and I
generally knock off between 12:00 and
1:00
midnight and one stop for meals in
between and and when I'm out of that
routine I really miss it for instance if
on our way for more than a few days I
start missing that and I started wanting
that I love being in the studio and so I
think it's worked out good for me but
but it was a real problem at first yeah
for sure
you know I think people go through this
maybe I think people exaggerate it a lot
more than it should be exaggerated I
believe if you go into the studio
there's no doubt about the fact that
painting is not always about the great
stroke
the great stroke that brings it all
together that now makes sense of you
know all of the work and all of the
effort it's also about priming canvases
and we're sweeping the floor it's about
mixing paint it's about so many things
and you know what people can call it
luck they can call it whatever they want
but the more time I spend in the studio
a luckier I get
and I don't entertain people that sit
around for a year waiting to be inspired
that's